salut a tous j'espère que vous n'êtes
pas fait de nos cerveaux avec l'énigme
d'hier vous savez tous les jours une
énigme pendant 32 jours et surtout je
donne d'abord la réponse de l'énigme de
la veille avant de donner la nouvelle
la réponse de l'énigme de la veille
c'est sûrement une des énigmes et plus
compliqué que je connaisse
il faut créer un paradoxe dans le
paradoxe donc la question que vous allez
poser
peu importe qui vous choisissez puisque
tu mais elles sont pas identifiables
avant que je continue j'espère que vous
avez regardé de l'énigme parce que là je
donne la solution
donc peu importe lequel des deux auquel
vous allez vous intéressait peu importe
la porte puisque toute manière rien
n'est identifiable et tout se ressemble
la question que vous allez poser c'est
si je demande à ton collègue qu'elle est
la porte du paradis il me désignera
laquelle et là vous vous dites vous avez
raison je sais pas si c'est celui qui
m'ont qui dit la vérité qui va me
répondre mais justement ce qu'est malin
c'est que la porte que va vous désigner
la personne à qui vous posez la question
sera toujours la porte de l'enfer
pourquoi parce que vous avez intégré les
deux dans la manière de répondre en
faisant ça vous intégrez forcément le
mensonge dans la réponse puisque si la
personne à qui vous adresser et la
personne qui ment le diable alors il
devrait vous montrer la porte du paradis
puisque dieu montrait le paradis mais
comme c'est un menteur il va inverser la
réponse est montrée d'enfer mais si
c'est dû à qui vous adressez il à dire
la vérité et vous montrer la porte que
désignerait le diable c'est à dire la
porte de l'enfer donc en posant cette
question vous serez qu'elle porte et
l'enfer et donc par déduction qu'elle
portait le paraître c'est hyper tordu
mais par contre 100% logique et 100%
difficile aussi c'est pour ça que
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui sera plus simple
énigme numéro 21 pour la team menthe à
l'eau j'ai pris un petit papier parce
qu'il faut qu'elle soit très précises
imaginons qu'on ait fait un concours
d'énigmes que depuis le début de cette
série spéciale était en effet un
concours denim et que pour ce concours
cinq personnes jouent et julie naïs
david thomas et albert et que j'ai pu
tirer les conclusions suivantes à savoir
thomas fut ni premier ni dernier julie a
résolu plus d'énigmes que nice david a
résolu plus d'énigmes que thomas thomas
a résolu plus d'énigmes qu'albert mais
moins que julie naïs a résolu plus
d'énigmes que david question qui a
résolu le moins d'énigmes vous refait
rapidement thomas ne fut ni premier ni
dernier julie a eu plus de points que la
liste david a fait plus que thomas
thomas a fait plus qu albert mais moins
que je lis et naïs a fait plus que david
c'est tout à fait possible de trouver la
réponse et de la logique pure et dure
dès que vous avez trouvé dit j'ai trouvé
dans les commentaires et laisser un
pouce en l'air pour qu'on voie le nom
personnes qui ont réussi à résoudre
l'énigme profiter encore du soleil qui
restent pendant quelques jours n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de
partir parce que le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
oui